>> Gayle Osterberg:
Good afternoon everyone.
It is already afternoon.
This day, we plan it for
months and months, and it seems
like it goes by so quickly,
because it's so fun.
My name is Gayle Osterberg.
I'm the director
of communications
for the Library of Congress.
And I'm so happy to
welcome you hear today.
Thank you for coming.
We're thrilled to see
so many book lovers
as we celebrate reading and
literacy throughout the day
at the National Book Festival.
The 18th National Book Festival.
I want to take a minute
to say a big thank you
to our festival sponsors.
Without their support, not only
would this event not be free,
but it just wouldn't
be possible at all.
And so I would encourage you to,
at some point during the course
of your day, stop down
on the expo floor.
Many of our sponsors are
exhibiting down there.
Tell them thank you for their
support of reading and literacy.
One of, and importantly, if
you have enjoyed your day,
and if you've enjoyed the
Book Festival in past years,
I would also encourage you
to consider contributing
to the event.
It's very easy, loc.gov/donate.
No contribution is too small,
and they all help ensure
that this event can
continue into the future.
One of our sponsors, PBS,
is here on the concourse
downstairs.
They are sharing out a
brand-new series that begins
in just a couple weeks,
The Great American Read.
They kicked it off
earlier this summer
with host Meredith Vieira,
and they surveyed readers just
like yourself across the
country, developed a list
of America's 100 favorite
novels, and they are asking
that you stop downstairs
and vote.
And throughout the fall,
they will be having weekly
programs talking about the books
on the list, talking about
the voting and counting
down to announcing
America's favorite novel.
So I encourage you to go
see them, cast your vote.
And then a couple of important
logistical notes, everyone,
please turn off your cellphones.
Very important.
Also very important, our next
author will be signing books
from 2 to 3 in line number four.
So please make a note of
that as well, because I know
after hearing him, you're
all going to want to go get
that book and have
him sign it for you.
His book, his 14th suspense
novel, is called The Switch.
I don't know how many of you
have had a chance to read it.
I read this book in one day.
I was flying home
to see my parents
for my dad's 80th birthday
after a series of long delays
at the airport, which
really worked well for me
because I was reading
this page-turner
and didn't want to put it down.
I got home around 10, and I
told my parents I would have
to see them in the morning,
because I was really tired.
And I went to bed, and
I turned off the lights,
and I finished this book
with my cellphone light on so
that they wouldn't know I was
still awake not talking to them.
Actually, that is a true story.
In addition to being an
incredible page-turner
and also really establishing
for me a lasting craving
for cold brew coffee, something
that I loved about this book was
that in an hour of great need,
the protagonist, Michael Tanner,
turned to a library for
information and safety.
And being that I love
our Library of Congress
and libraries in general, I
loved that part of the plot.
The Associated Press
calls this author a master
at making the reader feel every
emotion, jump at every shock
and squirm with every twist.
Please welcome the
author of bestselling
and award-winning novels,
including The Zero Hour,
High Crimes and Buried Secrets,
the master of the modern
thriller in his debut appearance
at the National Book
Festival, Joseph Finder.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Finder: Thank
you, Gayle, and thank you
for saying my name right.
I am Finder not Finder.
A few years ago, I
was on book tour,
and I got on the
plane in Boston.
And I was ready to
set off on my tour,
and I saw someone sitting there
on the plane reading
one of my books.
So I thought to myself,
do you say something?
Like, what do you do?
I don't know.
So I kept going, and it
turned out I was seated
in the row right
behind this guy.
And I could see him
between the seats.
I could see him reading
the book.
So I couldn't resist it
anymore, and I finally said,
I stuck my head in between
the seats and I said,
so, the book, how is it?
Eh. I said, it gets a lot better
by the end of the first chapter.
I feel like I'm in a really
interesting place these days
with all of this
information swirling
around about Donald
Trump and Russia
and intelligences agencies
and the deep state,
because the first thing I ever
wrote for money was a book
about a rich, powerful American
businessman who was trying
to conceal his connections
to the Kremlin.
That was my first book,
a nonfiction book,
called Red Carpet, long out
of print and deservedly so.
It was in part the story of a
guy named Dr. Armand Hammer.
Some of you may remember
who he is.
Armand Hammer was
an interesting guy.
He was the CEO of
Occidental Petroleum.
He was known as a
philanthropist.
He was also known as someone
who had a personal
connection to Lenin.
And I was a graduate student
at Harvard, and I was training
to be a Soviet expert.
And I read this People Magazine
article on Dr. Armand Hammer,
billionaire oil tycoon.
And by the way, he is
the great-grandfather
of Armie Hammer.
Do you know the actor,
Armie Hammer?
That's his great-great
grandson, his great grandson.
So, I was reading this
article in People Magazine
about Dr. Armand Hammer.
I was sitting at the
dentist reading this article
on Armand Hammer.
It talked about how
he was a friend
of Lenin's and a philanthropist.
The thing is, at the same time,
I happen to be reading the
letters of Lenin in Russian
for a course I was
taking in grad school.
These were the letters of
Lenin they don't translate
from Russian to English.
So, and in this letter, I
found one, in this collection
of letters, I found a
letter from Lenin himself
to comrade Armand Hammer.
And I looked at that, and
I just thought, comrade.
I remember when Lenin
called someone comrade,
that meant he was a member of
the Communist Party, for sure.
And I didn't quite get that.
I was kind of surprised.
And I did a little research,
and I found out that
Armand Hammer's father,
a man named Julius Hammer,
founded the American
Communist Party.
And Armand Hammer went over
to Moscow to meet Lenin
as an agent of his father's.
And I thought, now
this is interesting.
Here is this great
capitalist, this billionaire,
who is a friend of Lenin's,
and I thought there's
a book in here.
And I thought, you
know something?
I want to write.
And I have to confess to
you, what I really wanted
to write was fiction, but
I didn't have the courage.
I thought, nonfiction is safer.
So I'm going to write
this safer,
easier thing, this
nonfiction book.
So I scored an interview
with Dr. Armand Hammer
in his office in New York.
And he was by then 85 or
so, and I was scheduled
to talk to him for two hours.
And I started asking him
general biographical questions.
And about 15 minutes into
my interview, I said,
so tell me about your father.
Your father, Julius Hammer,
was a friend of Lenin's
and a founder of the
American Communist Party.
I think that's quite
interesting.
Hammer stood up, and
he said, all right,
this interview is over.
Get this guy out of here.
And he kicked me out.
I thought, I think
there's something there.
So I went to Moscow.
I went to Moscow as a tourist,
and in those days, you had to go
on a tour within tourists.
And I, starting with some names
I got from Russian emigres,
I eventually tracked down a
number of people in Moscow.
One was a man who
claimed to be the son
of Armand Hammer's brother,
Victor Hammer, who was living
in Moscow, a man named Armond
Victovitch [phonetic] Hammer,
living in Moscow all his life.
He had been kept as a hostage.
And I also met an
old man who claimed
to be Armand Hammer's
case officer.
That is, Hammer worked
for the KGB,
or the NKGB as it was
called in those days.
Now this was interesting because
I had a source in the CIA named,
who was in the CIA, as
kind of legendary chief
of counterintelligence
names James Jesus Angleton.
And Angleton, the chief
of counterintelligence
for the CIA told me that he
believed Armand Hammer was a
Soviet agent, and I
didn't believe him.
I said what's the proof?
He kind of was vague, which
told me there really wasn't
any proof.
But I decided I was going to
find that proof, and I did.
I found this case officer.
So, at the end of this day in
which I had found both this man
who was the son of Hammer's
brother and this case officer,
the phone rang in my hotel
in Moscow, and it was someone
with the MVD with the police
asking me what I was doing
in Moscow.
Because I clearly
wasn't on my tour group.
And I quite bluntly
told him I was doing
investigative journalism.
And he said, Moscow
does not believe
in investigative journalism.
And he suggested that I
leave the country right away.
Because if I didn't,
something would happen to me.
And you know what, I
didn't need to find out.
I left, I actually left
the country at that point.
I started getting phone calls
when I was back in the US
from people who worked
for Dr. Hammer,
who worked for Occidental
Petroleum who told me,
one guy told me, hey,
piece of friendly advice,
Dr. Hammer is very litigious.
And he's going to
sue you for libel.
He's going to sue you
out of your socks.
I remember that expression.
Going to sue you
out of your socks.
So, I was a graduate student
living in Central Square
in Cambridge, and all
I could afford to pay
for rent was $245 a month.
And I'm thinking, sue
me out of my socks?
These are socks with
holes in them, you know.
Hammer then called my faculty
advisor at Harvard and told him
that he was prepared to
make Harvard a large gift.
He wanted to give Harvard
a gift of $20 million
and the Hammer papers,
his personal papers.
Just one request,
if you could get rid
of this annoying graduate
student named Joseph Finder.
And I believe this is the
first time in the history
of Harvard University that
they ever turned down money.
But they actually
turned that one down.
And the day before
my book went on sale,
I was reading the
New York Times.
I was in New York, and I got
it, you know, remember back
in the days you could get
the New York Times early.
You could get it at
midnight before it came
out in the morning.
I was so excited.
And there I found on the Op
Ed page of the Times a piece
by a lawyer named Louie Nizer.
And Louie Nizer, who was
once a well-known attorney,
was also Armand Hammer's lawyer.
And this was a piece
about libel law.
And in this piece, Louie Nizer
says that one of his clients
and dear friends has been
libeled in a new book.
And of course, according to
the conventional definitions,
his client was a public
figure, and therefore,
couldn't sue for libel.
He said, it's time to
change the libel laws.
And I read that, and I just
went, oh, this is not good.
This is trouble.
They then, Hammer then had his
people talk to my publisher
and tell them that they
considered this book libelous,
and they wanted to
sue for libel.
And my publisher, of
course, was nervous.
Because that's what
publishers are.
They get nervous about
these sorts of things.
And they said well,
it's a small print run.
They printed 10,000 copies.
That's it.
When it's done, we
won't print anymore.
That'll be the end of the book.
Don't worry about it.
They couldn't kill it off.
They couldn't kill the book
off by threat of a libel suit
or by threatening me directly.
So, Hammer had his people
buy up as many copies
as they could find in the
stores around the country.
And the book sold really well.
I mean it sold out.
This is what publishers
call a clean sell through.
And I realized during this
whole time that there was,
I was able to say a lot about
Armand Hammer in my nonfiction,
but I was too responsible and
too determined not to be sued
for libel to tell
the whole story.
And I realized that that
man I had met in Moscow,
that Armand Victovitch Hammer,
was probably not the son
of Armand Hammer's brother.
It was probably Armand
Hammer's son himself.
Because what I had been told is
that they kept him as a hostage
to ensure that Armand Hammer,
who went to Moscow in the 20s,
met a woman, met a
Russian woman, had a baby,
left the country, left the wife
and the child behind,
I think as a hostage.
Anyway, I realized there
were aspects to this story
that I really couldn't
tell in nonfiction.
I had to tell in fiction.
I decided to give fiction a try.
Now remember, I was afraid to
write a novel because I thought
that was too dangerous.
It was too risky.
I wanted to do something safer
like write a nonfiction
book, right.
What I discovered,
actually, in writing fiction,
was that people would talk
to me and tell me things,
reveal things, that they would
never tell the New York Times
or the Wall Street Journal.
It was the fact that
I was writing fiction
that made it safe for
them to talk to me.
And I was able to find
out all kinds of things
and tell all kinds
of things in fiction
that you can't do in nonfiction.
What I love to do, What I've
loved from the beginning,
is finding things
out, doing research.
Finding out inside information
that we're not supposed to know
and passing that
along to my readers.
So, for instance, my first novel
called The Moscow Club dealt
with a fictional Armand Hammer.
But its plot was
about a coup de tat
in the Kremlin against
Gorbachev.
And you know, I had read a
lot of Frederick Forsyth,
and it occurred to me it would
be kind of cool to actually put
in real names the
way Forsyth did.
So I put in Gorbachev.
I put in the names of the people
who would pull of this coup,
this fictional coup,
against Gorbachev.
The book came out, finally,
in February of 1991.
And one of the first
reviewers talked
about how its plot
was farfetched,
this plot about a coup
against Gorbachev.
Farfetched.
Six months later, this is August
of '91, I get awakened early
in the morning by one
of my sources in the CIA
who said, are you watching CNN?
I said, no, what are
you talking about?
He said put it on, and I did.
There were tanks rumbling
through the streets of Moscow.
Gorbachev was under house
arrest in the Black Sea.
There had been a coup de tat.
The guy said to me, do you see
who's involved in the coup?
And I realized the people
who had pulled off the
real-life coup attempt
against Gorbachev were the
people I named in my novel.
He said, you think
someone read the book?
So, it wasn't, it wasn't that
I had any particular talent
at Kremlinology or Sovietology.
It wasn't that I could
predict the future.
What I realized is, I was
willing to listen to some
of the crazier theories
out there.
Some of the rumors that
were circulating in Langley,
Virginia, and take
some of them seriously.
I was basically willing
to stick my neck out
and make a fool out of myself.
And it so happened in this case,
I didn't make a fool
out of myself.
But I learned in the process,
here was a way to sort of write
about real stuff, write
about espionage and spy stuff
and international relations, do
it in a way that's entertaining
and that actually provides
new inside information.
But I have to admit, I didn't
always stick my neck out.
I was working on a book, a long
time ago, on the Russian mafia.
Russian organized crime.
Now, as some of you may know,
Russian organized crime has
taken an interesting turn
over the last few years.
There are now oligarchs
who are now connected
with organized crime who has
taken most of Russia's assets
out and who are now some
of the billionaires.
I wanted to do a story about
what it was like to actually be
in one of these groups
in my novel.
So I found a source
who was in one
of these organized
crime groups in Moscow
who said he would sneak me in.
I would just wear a fur hat
and look like a Russian.
That means wear kind of a
schlubby overcoat, you know,
and bad shoes and a fur hat.
And I would sneak
into this meeting,
and I would basically observe,
and people would
think I was Russian.
That was fine.
And this would be
this really cool bit
of research I could
do for my novel.
So I get a phone call
at my hotel room again.
The guy says, there's a rumor
going around that someone
from the CIA is about to
infiltrate our meeting tonight.
And they think this
someone from the CIA is you.
I said I'm not in
the CIA, really.
And they said, that's
not what they believe.
If you go, I can't tell you
what could happen to you.
Well, I had a little
baby at that point.
I just thought, is it worth
it really to write a novel?
I don't think so.
So I left Moscow as soon as
I could, the next morning,
decided not to go
to that meeting.
I decided that as interested
as I was in the Russia mafia,
it wasn't worth getting
killed over for a thriller.
By the way, I wasn't in the CIA.
Although I admit I
thought about it.
Since I was sort of a Russia
expert back in the day,
that is, I spoke Russian.
I knew Russian history.
I knew Soviet politics.
I was naturally recruited
to the CIA.
They did that a lot at
Yale, by the way, you know.
I was recruited, and
here is the problem.
I had read a lot of Robert
Ludlum's thrillers, you know,
the Bourne Identity
and things like that.
So, I thought that if you worked
for the CIA they gave
you a Glock pistol
and several fake passports
and a Swiss bank account.
And it turned out, in
fact, I would be sitting
at a cubicle translating
Tractor Digest
from Russian to English all day.
And I thought, this
doesn't sound quite
as interesting as I expected.
So basically, writing about,
you know, the sorghum harvest
in the Soviet Union in the
Ukraine 1953 to 1955, basically,
Robert Ludlum ruined it for me.
Now, speaking of Ludlum, one of
the questions I get asked most
of all is, about my books,
is it going to be a movie?
You hear this all the time
because the book hasn't
really graduated from college
until it's become
a movie, you know.
That's how people
think about it, right.
I have actually had two movies
made, which beats the odds.
Two, one good, rather,
one good, one not so good.
Which also beats the odds.
The one that I like
is called High Crimes,
which stars Morgan
Freeman and Ashely Judd.
And this is a story about
a woman who's a professor
at Harvard Law School.
In the movie, of course,
she's not a professor
at Harvard Law School.
In the movie she's a
criminal defense attorney
in San Francisco.
Anyway. And in the
book, she discovers
that her husband has some sort
of a secret life and is accused
of a terrible atrocity, and
she decides to defend him
in the military courtroom
where she is not an expert.
And she brings in
Morgan Freeman,
who is an expert
in military law.
So this is the basic setup.
It's a military trial.
This is the basic
setup of High Crimes.
So my agent, my Hollywood agent
called me up and said, you know,
this movie actually
might get made.
Because there's a lot of heat
around it and a lot of buzz.
And when there's heat and
buzz in Hollywood, well,
there's always heat and buzz
in Hollywood, isn't there?
The truth is, 90, 95% of
books that get optioned
for the movies will
never make it into,
never become a movie or TV show.
So, I was a little
skeptical about this.
And I said, he said no, no,
my agent said no, really.
We have a director.
His name is Carl Franklin.
He wants to make this.
We have a really
good screenplay.
Ashley Judd wants
to play the lead.
Morgan Freeman wants
to play the other lead.
This is going to get greenlit.
I said okay.
If it really is, I want a cameo.
Is that so much to ask?
I mean, I did write
the book, right?
I said, Hitchcock did it.
So my agent said Joe,
you're not Hitchcock.
He was the director
of the movies.
He put himself in the movie.
You are the writer of the book.
And in the totem pole that is
Hollywood, I'm below ground.
That's just the way it works.
So he said you're not
going to get a cameo.
I'm sorry.
I said well ask them anyway.
So one day my agent called
me a few weeks later,
and he said all right.
Good news and bad news.
What do you want to hear first?
I said the good news always.
He said the good news is, the
director has agreed to put you
in a cameo in the movie.
The bad news, you're going
to have to shave your head,
because you're in
a military jury.
You're going to be on the
jury in a military trial,
and you are basically
playing a marine.
And they're going to shave your
head high and tight, you know.
And I said that's fine.
I'll go and do it myself.
I'll go out to Great Cuts
and have this done, you know.
No, no, no, no, no, no,
you've got to have it done
by the makeup and hair people.
So they flew me out there,
and I met with the director.
And remember, I was supposed to
be in the jury in this movie.
Now, you know, they don't
really show the jury very often
in movies.
They sort of pan across the
jury kind of slowly sometimes.
I knew that the odds were
I would hit the cutting
room floor.
I would not actually
be in the movie.
But still, being in the jury,
being on the movie set at all,
sounded like something cool.
So there I was talking
to the director before I
went to hair and makeup.
And he said, you know, you've
got a certain authority.
I said, yes, I do.
He said, let's promote this guy.
And on the spot, I was promoted
from mere member of the jury
to member of the
prosecution team.
I was one of the prosecutors.
And I got to sit at
the prosecutor's table.
My job, and they told
me, my job was to glare
at Morgan Freeman, all right.
So I was practicing this.
I was sort of staring
at him, glaring at me.
He glared back, you know.
They never gave me
acting lessons.
They never told me what to do.
They just told me,
glare at Morgan Freeman.
And in fact, my character, later
in the movie, beats him up.
And it wasn't me.
It was someone else.
Anyway. So the guy playing
the prosecutor turned
to me when I sat down.
There I was in my high and tight
and my marine uniform
and everything.
He said, so, how you doing?
I'm Mike.
And I said hey Mike.
I'm Joe. I had made a deal with
the director that I was going
to be incognito on the set.
They did not want
people on the set to know
that I had written the book.
Why? Presumably because I would,
maybe because actors would come
up to me and say, this
line isn't right, is it?
How would you tweak this line?
Don't you think we
should add something here?
For whatever reason,
they were threatened
by having the writer on the set.
Interesting, isn't it?
I agreed to basically
be incognito,
which meant that I would not
tell them who I was, right.
So he said, so the guy
playing the prosecutor said
to me, I'm Mike.
And I said I'm Joe.
And he said, so, where you from?
I said, Boston.
He said, and this was
in LA on the soundstage.
He said, they flew you in
from Boston for this part?
Yeah. He said, do
you know somebody?
No. He then said, all right,
so let me tell you
about High Crimes.
Let me tell you about
the book and the movie
and how they're different
actually.
And I want to tell
you a little bit
about the thematic
underpinnings of this story.
You really need to know how
this really works thematically.
And he spent about five
minutes telling me all
about High Crimes.
Telling me the story.
Telling me what it
was really about.
And I couldn't take it anymore.
And I finally said.
I said Mike, my name
is Joseph Finder.
I wrote the book the
movie's based on.
He said, oh man.
Morgan, Ashley, this
guy wrote High Crimes.
So my cover was blown.
But I decided since my cover was
blown, this was my opportunity
to meet Morgan Freeman.
Try and stop me.
Because I had been told
not to talk to the stars.
Below the line, that's okay.
I could talk to, but don't
talk to Ashley or Morgan.
Leave them alone.
As an extra, do not
talk to the stars.
I said okay.
I saw Morgan Freeman standing
there during a break with a guy
who looked a lot like him.
It turned out to be his stand-in
who is also his personal
assistant.
So I went up to him, and I
said excuse me, Mr. Freeman,
I just wanted to say hi.
My name is Joe Finder.
I wrote the book High Crimes
that the movie's based on.
And Freeman stared at me, and
he turned to his stand-in,
and he said this gentleman
here says he wrote the book the
movie's based on like I give a.
And like the blood
rushed to my head.
And I just thought,
Morgan Freeman is supposed
to be the nicest
guy in Hollywood.
Oh man. And he went, ha,
ha, ha, I got you, didn't I?
So the amazing thing is, I was
sitting on the set of a movie
that I had made up in my
head a few years earlier.
I was sitting, I
remember sitting
at my computer describing
the courtroom,
describing every detail of it,
which they now perfectly had.
And I thought, how cool is this?
I made this up, just me
sitting in my office,
sitting at a computer.
It takes 500 people to
make one of these movies.
But I could do it myself.
I thought that was kind of cool.
I acted, I use that term
lightly, I acted in five scenes,
which meant I was
shooting for five days.
And I got paid for this.
I got paid $200 per day,
so I got paid $1,000
to act in High Crimes.
But there's a rule that if
you're in a movie for three days
or more, you have to join SAG,
the Screen Actors'
Guild, which costs $1,500.
But I joined it.
I had no choice.
There's a lesson there.
I'm not sure what it is.
Anyway. The other
movie that's made
from my books was called
Paranoia staring Harrison Ford
and Gary Oldman.
And you're thinking, I
haven't heard of that movie.
It's a Harrison Ford movie,
I haven't heard of it?
There's a reason you
haven't heard about it.
The less said about
that one, the better.
My attitude about movie
adaptations, people would say
to me things like so,
what did you think
about what they did to Paranoia?
What do you think?
I remember there
was a great line
from the author James M. Cain
who wrote Double Indemnity.
He was asked, how do you feel
about what the movies
did to your book?
And he pointed to the
shelf and he said,
they didn't do anything.
The book's still here.
And that's sort of how I feel
is, the book is still here.
I don't care, as long
as it works as a movie.
So, I need to tell you a secret
and that is, which I'm telling
to this small group here
because we're in genre fiction.
We're all, you know,
you're my people.
That I use my fiction
as a way to comment
on what's going on around us.
I sneak it in.
And unlike the movies,
I'm the boss.
Which I like.
My most recent book
is called The Switch.
It's about a businessman in
Boston, a coffee entrepreneur.
One day he's going
through LAX, the airport,
and he's in the security
line, and he reaches
down to grab his MacBook
Air from the security line.
And he sees two identical
MacBook Airs, and he picks
up the wrong one, goes onto
the plane, gets home to Boston
and realizes he has
a computer here
that belongs to a US Senator.
And on it, is some top-secret
classified information.
And I thought, now this
could be kind of interesting
as I was putting this together.
My hero's life is going
to be turned upside down.
Why? Because he is not
going to return it.
That's all I had.
And that's what I created.
So Switch, The Switch,
turns out to be
about this one guy's
struggle to survive.
But on another level,
it's about something else.
It's about how we're
giving up our own privacy.
The secret information on
this computer has to do
with an NSA surveillance
program that I describe
in the book and which is true.
There's a sequence in
the book when my hero,
Michael Tanner, has
to go on the lam.
You know, in thrillers you have
to go on the lam quite a bit.
I'm not sure what the lam is,
but people go on the lam a lot.
All right.
Michael realizes he can't rent
a car, because that's going
to set off lights
all over the place.
He can't use his credit cards.
He's got about $6 in his wallet.
He can't use his ATM card.
Can't get cash.
And there are cameras
everywhere he goes.
I wanted to sort of, in this
scene, in this sequence,
show the extent to which I think
we have given up our privacy.
We all check, you know
those privacy notices
that have been popping up all
over the place whenever you go
to a website recently?
The last couple of
weeks I've noticed this.
I don't if it's a
European thing.
I'm not exactly sure.
But there's a little check here
to indicate you have
no privacy anymore,
which is basically what we do.
We don't even, nobody reads
those privacy documents.
I am here today representing
genre fiction.
Specifically, mysteries
and thrillers.
I hate the term genre fiction.
It is condescending.
But at the same time,
I love my genre.
I love mysteries and thrillers.
I feel that it enables
me to tell a story,
and at the same time, reveal
some inside information,
something important,
something I think we should be
talking about.
But let me be clear, my
job is to entertain you.
I want you to stay up too
late to turn the pages
and be a wreck the
next day at work.
That's really my objective.
Because, thank you.
We all crave stories.
Whether through TV or stories
through movies or stories
through that superior content
delivery system, books.
But we also love
learning things.
Finding out more about the
world, which works for me
because I love finding
things out
and telling people about them.
So I sort of feel that
I've traveled full circle
in my writing.
How could I not be obsessed
with another billionaire
American businessman
with hidden connections
to the Kremlin, right.
[ Applause ]
I heard steel dossier,
and you know,
I was hooked at that
point, right.
I mean this is an amazing story.
And I'm making light of it.
I will be honest,
I'm really worried
about what's going
on in our country.
I'm worried about
what's going to happen
when Mueller comes
out with his report.
This is not like Watergate.
There was no Fox News
in 1973 and 1974.
I worry about what's
happening at the FBI
and what's happening at the CIA.
In my new book, I mean imagine
how weird it is, by the way,
to be writing conspiracy stories
at a time when we're hearing
about conspiracies every day,
coming out of the White House.
That sort of blows my mind.
In my new book, I deal with
the Russian notion of kompromat
which is the use of secret,
damaging secret information
to blackmail or to
ensure loyalty.
In my new book, it's used
against a female judge
who's made one bad mistake.
That book is called
Judgment, and it's due
out at the end of next year.
It may not be the only
book called Judgment.
This is, I don't know.
I worry about the
title, you know.
There are other books
called Judgment,
but you can't copyright
titles I learned.
So I've decided that
my next book is going
to be called The Da Vinci Code.
I'd love to answer
any questions.
[ Applause ]
Who would like to start?
>> Hi, short preamble.
My father worked for the
DOD for over 40 years.
>> For the DOJ?
>> For the DOD.
>> DOD.
>> Yep, everyone in this
room knows what that is.
>> I'm from Boston.
>> So, in the 70s he was
working with submarines.
And when Clancy's Hunt
for Red October came out,
I distinctly remember
watching him read that book,
and at a certain point in
the book, he said, what?
What? And he shut the book, went
to the phone, made a phone call
and said, have you
read Clancy's book?
Who is talking to him?
So my question for you
is, what is the process
like when a source
gives you information
that you know is delicious but
maybe shouldn't go in the book?
>> That's an excellent question.
Because it's almost
irresistible.
The investigative
journalist part
of me wants to get that out.
Wants to get whatever it is out.
But at the same time, if I
blow my sources, I've wrecked
for myself any other source
who wants to pay attention,
who wants to help me out.
So I have really decided
I have held things back
because I was told to.
So basically, I, unlike
Clancy, I basically tend
to observe those rules.
However, if I can find that
out by some other means,
that's what I try to do is try
to get it in there if possible.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm looking around.
Are there other questions?
Yes.
>> How do you pick, I know a lot
of your different books focus
on specific industries.
How do you decide that this guy
is going to be a coffee maker?
This guy is going to
work in [inaudible].
>> Right.
>> How do you pick those?
>> I sort of, I basically
think of the story,
think of the character, and
then I'll decide what I want
to learn about.
And it so happened when
I was writing The Switch,
that I was really interested in
coffee companies and the sale
of coffee and artisan coffee
and how that's happened.
And I decided this would
be a really interesting way
of exploring that.
When I wrote Judgment I decided,
I'm going to look at what it's
like to be a judge, because I
have no idea what that's like.
So I sort of pick things almost
at random that appealed to me
and hoped that it appeals
to the readers as well.
This is probably
our last question,
because I've got to wrap it up.
>> So, when you were discussing
the potential CIA job that's
just sitting in a cubicle
translating almanacs,
the first thing I
actually thought
of is [inaudible] who's
basically running theme is
that people who did stuff
like that fought most
of the Cold War,
in so many words.
Do you think that there
is a compelling thriller
to be written about that from
the American side of things?
Or are we just too
impatient for that?
>> Are we just what?
>> Are we just too
impatient for that?
>> I think we're too
impatient for it.
I don't think it would
work really as a thriller.
And you know, there's a question
that I think about a lot
and that is, what did
spies do for us ultimately?
Did we quote/unquote win the
Cold War because of espionage?
And I think the answer is no.
And that, as much as I
value and respect the CIA,
you have to keep
in mind the utility
that spies give us is sometimes
not as much as people think
because of guys like
me who write stories
in which spies are
lotted [phonetic].
Anyway, let me wrap
it up right there.
Thank you so much.
>> Gayle Osterberg:
Oh thank you.
[ Applause ]